[Music]
Captain Marvel is here and the MCU will
never be the same again if you've been
keeping up to date with the film then
you'll know that there's a wealth of
controversy surrounding it that seems to
be overshadowing the movie itself whilst
it's hard to avoid this let's cast it
out of our minds for a minute and focus
on the film's plot it's ending and what
it teases for the future throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about Captain
Marvel including its final few scenes
and the ones that appear after the
credits it's full spoilers ahead on this
so if you don't want to know anything
about the movie and I highly suggest
that you turn off now but without the
way I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I explain it so you don't
have to ok so perhaps the biggest pot
twists in Captain Marvel is that the
scrolls are actually the good guys if
you've been following the comics then
you'll know that this is a pretty big
changeup and is arguably one of the
biggest twists since we found out that
shield were in fact Hydra the
kree-skrull war ravages the galaxy and
is the backdrop to this origin story
that centers around our heroine Carol
Danvers the kree-skrull war is happening
because the Kree are determined to rule
over the galaxy and when the Skrulls
start an uprising and the majority of
them were massacred whilst the rest were
turned into refugees looking for a new
home the Kree themselves are ruled by an
AI known as the supreme intelligence
this program takes the form of the
person that you respect the most and the
race worship it like a god however its
goal is to subjugate every other species
and planet in the galaxy whilst we never
discover who created it or where they
are now we can in fact look to the
comics for answers on this the supreme
intelligence is actually made from the
brain of one of the smartest Crees that
ever lived
eventually it evolves and develops its
own consciousness that helps it to
replace the Kree government as a ruler
so how does the supreme intelligence
play into the plot of Captain Marvel
well Captain Marvel opens with Carol
already as a citizen of Halle and one of
the kree's best soldiers while she has
black
Baxter her past it's clear she's having
certain things hidden from her yon rogue
her mentor trained sir as tough as he
can
stipulating that she can't use powers
and he ensures this with a device that
slows if I was down after this training
seen Carol visits the supreme
intelligence who appears as a met
Benning though Carol has no idea why
it's here that the plot is really
kick-started and Carol is sent on a
mission to rescue a Cree undercover from
a planet with the help of her team Carol
sneaks in but discovers that the
undercover is actually Talos a scroll
warrior who incapacitates and captures
her from here Captain Marvel manages to
escape and destroy the ship on which
she's held which is when we see her
crash land on Earth in a blockbusters
for those who were born after 2005
blockbusters is a bit like Netflix but
an actual location god I miss those days
anyway Tallis has learned from Captain
Marvel's memories about certain things
on the planet including Pegasus which is
a logo on her jacket
after the scroll started infiltrate
society Captain Marvel contacts you on
rock she learns that she has 22 hours
before they show up and she begins
working with fury and Coulson who show
up to investigate what's going on from
here the train scene happens when a
scroll shows up and attacks her and fury
discovers that at some point at
blockbusters the scroll swapped out the
real cool sin with one of their soldiers
fury manages to kill this scroll but the
one that Captain Marvel was chasing
manages to get away from the head of
shield division and played by Ben
Mendelsohn Fury is told to track down
Captain Marvel who finds her in a bar
that she remembers since Scrolls can't
absorb memories beyond 24 hours the two
learn to trust each other before heading
to Pegasus to see why the Skrulls are
interested here they learn that annette
bening character dr. wendy lawson has
been dead since 1989
they sneak off to the archives which is
when they're followed by gusta Kat Fury
called shield who show up however Fury
thinks something isn't quite right with
the shield leader and tricks him into
revealing he's a scroll which is when
the two escape from here the movie
becomes about Carol's rediscovery and
the reveal that she was a pilot that
apparently died during a test flight of
Lawsons new aircraft with the help of
her friend Maria she begins to unearth
her past
Talos arrives and explains the backstory
and it turns out that Lawson was
actually
Kri name marbella who's developing
technology to help the scrolls and scape
impression this tesseract powered ship
was shut down by yon rogue who killed my
Bell and captured Carol to use her as a
weapon
after she absorbed the ship's power
source in the ambush naturally Carol is
nick furious about the whole situation
and she changes her suit colours to
reflect her new mind state the new team
discover marbella ship is still in space
and journey there while she on Rogue
arrives on earth in space they discover
the tesseract and that squirrel refugees
have been living on the base since
marbella died
Carol takes the tesseract which goose
who is revealed to be a fleur kin at one
point eats yon rugs up and they captured
the scrolls while Carol dupes it out
with supreme intelligence Carol realizes
that the Kree are actually very scared
of her as they can't control her and
she's finally able to get free and fight
star force Maria and fury escaped to
earth with goose and the scrolls but
they are chased by cream I don't wanna
spoil too much but fury loses his eye
and the battle continues on earth
you're on rogue lands on earth just as
Ronan shows up with a bombing fleet but
carol is able to make quick work of them
and sends Ronan running finally Carol
finds yon Rob who says that she is
nothing and can't beat him without her
powers but in an Indiana Jones esque
Easter Egg Carol just blasts him sending
him back home to the Kree with the
warning that she's coming
Carol gives fury back his pager which
he's upgraded to be able to send signals
across the galaxy and with the scroll
she journeys into space
promising to find them a new home we
then see fury in his office with goose
wearing an eyepatch which is when
Coulson comes in and hands him a box of
fake eyes which he closes and states
that the planet is going to need more
people like her to protect earth the
protector initiative is on his screen
but when he looks at a photo and it says
Carol Avenger Danvers on the side of her
f-16 he smiles and changes the title to
the Avengers initiative obviously
there's still a lot of big questions
that loom over this though so where did
Carol and the Skrulls go unfortunately
we don't know and it's not really an
indicator in the comics to guess where
this could be however it's a safe
assumption to make that they will be far
away from the Kree secondly did Carol
and the wall well if we use Ronan as a
barometer
I think it's pretty safe to say that she
did in guardians of the galaxy which is
sat long after Captain Marvel Ronan is
an outcast rather than the supreme
accuser sure he still wants to rule the
galaxy but the fact that he's no longer
in a position to do this immediately
clearly indicates that the Kree Empire
has fallen to me this signifies that
Carroll did in fact stop the war however
this may be played out in a sequel for
the film if it ever happens and now on
to the post-credits scenes
Captain Marvel has two post-credit
scenes and if you've already seen the
leaks then chances are that you know
what they are I think down the line
these will kind of be looked upon badly
as once future movies have been released
these weren't really had much the first
credit scene involves Captain Marvel
showing up at Avengers HQ after the
events of infinity war to encounter the
rest of the survivors of the snap
Captain Marvel and Co have managed to
get Nick Fury's pager but they are
unsure of exactly what the signal it
means before it cuts out Captain Marvel
and steps forward saying that she's here
to answer the call and asks where Nick
Fury is Caroline Black Widow share the
screen and it's clear that the MCU is
heading towards a more female focused
journey with these two of the helm the
scene is ripped straight from avengers
endgame hence why I think down the line
it won't be viewed so favorably as once
that movies out this won't really add
anything the second post credits scene
in bulk scoots the cat in Fury's office
coughing up the tesseract this scene
ends the film on a lighter note that
neatly ties some of the movie's events
into the greater universe so that's
everything you need to know about
Captain Marvel and what happens in its
ending if you've seen the movie make
sure you leave your comments below and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
full breakdown of the Game of Thrones
trailer which should be linked at the
end this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like you hit subscribe
thanks again to take the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]